how to market your workshops if you're
an entrepreneur and you're selling
workshops and you want people to know
about it you want people to call you up
and say come into my school my store my
business whatever it is to learn about
your workshops then today I'm going to
give you three strategies on how to
promote those workshops and it comes on
the back of a question from one of my
readers preacher Jay preacher Jay you
wrote sin to say that he's marking these
workshops trying to teach young people
how to be entrepreneurs and he's
focusing on students and he's trying to
figure out how do I get the word out
about my workshops so preacher Jay here
is my three-step strategy for how to
promote your workshops
the first one is partnerships okay if
you want to go out and promote your
workshops you have to find people who
are willing to showcase them so in your
case that may be schools and maybe
colleges it may be groups you can look
them up online you can go to networking
events you can see where these people
are hanging out and contact them if you
are just trying to build up a list one
of my favorite resources is a website
called jigsaw its jigsaw com
I'm not filling with it but I love the
service we can find names of people
phone numbers email addresses that cost
you about a dollar per lead and you can
reach out to them and say here's what
I'm doing and make sure you're reaching
out to them with something special
something memorable something different
because they're getting pitch a lot by
people just like you so you have to have
a different angle when you're telling me
about your workshops just like you did
in your email and you got to tell me
what's different about it teaching
students to be entrepreneurs it's a
great message but it's not powerful
enough why what's so what's the reason
behind this what do you stand for is it
to get kids off the street is it to
teach people that there's another way
it's not just going to work for a big
company you can start your own thing if
you have to have some passion here
because again these people are being
pitched all the time by people just like
you and to get them to pay attention to
you you have to have a message that is
worth spreading
so work on that message and start
building your list and reaching out to
people ok that's your first step the
second step is getting the media ok if
you are a workshop lead
you're a thought leader you have
something to say you have a powerful
opinion and you should be an expert and
as entrepreneurs we should all be
experts at what we do so what I want you
to do is start building up a list of
media people who are targeting your area
I don't know if you're looking at just
doing it in your city in your state
you're trying to go nationwide whatever
it is wherever you're trying to start
build up a media list and give them
something worth talking about again this
ties to why do people need your workshop
is it that students are struggling and
they're on the street and this is a way
for them to get off of it is it that
young people want to be entrepreneurs
but they don't have enough training in
the schools like what is it what what is
the reason why I need to sign up for
your workshop I shouldn't have to ask
you this question it should be in your
message and you send an email to
somebody it should be a parent what it
is that you do the benefit why I want to
connect with you okay media are always
looking for stores so if you can create
a great story with a hook that promotes
you it's not a sales pitch but it
showcases your expertise it starts to
build awareness and people who are
reading that will see your name will see
your website will say I need to have
that in my school or my college or my
university and they'll contact you it's
such a great way to reach people because
it's not used screaming it's somebody
talking on your behalf right if a
newspaper publishes you it's them saying
hey this is a credible credible person
this is somebody who you should listen
to and it dramatically increases the
chances of people noticing you and it's
not that hard to reach out to the media
and get published the media are looking
for stories constantly they're
constantly looking for experts to give
them content that's their job is to find
great content you're making their job
easier so build your list of reporters
and start reaching it the third thing I
would do is I would start recording the
workshops or recording your message and
get it up online make youtube videos
even if it's something simple just like
I'm doing right now you and talk in
front of a camera it's not even you
doing your workshop it's just you
front of a camera talking to start
building momentum one it'll make you a
better speaker if the more practice you
have the more you go through the
exercise the better you're gonna become
but two it'll help start building a
movement you want people spreading your
stuff you want people talking about you
I've gotten gigs with big companies from
my videos because they see my passion
for entrepreneurs and it could be me
helping them explain how to market to
entrepreneurs
it could be me helping them with the
program it could be me doing a workshop
facilitation creating content for them
whatever it is I've gotten tons of
opportunities from the content I produce
a lot of it to the videos or through the
blog posts that I put up you need to
showcase your expertise and it'll also
help give you a sense of what kind of
content is sticking with people where
you can tell on your videos how many
views they have how many comments they
have are people liking our people
sharing it that can form a great content
base to make your workshops even better
but the main goal here is getting your
message out so for anybody who's
promoting a workshop or anybody who's
trying to showcase themselves as a
thought leader if it's workshops if it's
seminars if it's books if it's being a
radio show if it's doing anything where
you are a thought leader then follow
that process one again reach out to
potential partners people who can
promote you people who can bring you in
and showcase you number two make sure
that you're out there talking to the
media
create a list reach out to them on a
regular basis give them value don't sell
them give them value make them want to
talk about you because you're giving
them a great story with a great hook and
number three start recording yourself
create a YouTube channel start building
momentum start building traction
become a better speaker because you're
practicing more those three steps have
worked for me I've worked for tons of
other experts and I know they're gonna
work for you believe those are you
watching like a video please give it a
thumbs up below it always makes me want
to do more and I'd love to hear we have
to think you have a question about your
business leave it below I'm a good video
response you have a different comment
about this
the on particularly verbal oh I love
Cena's come in thank you so much and
I'll see you soon